why do you always match your head in
your pants now huh oh is it marrying wha
oh whoops yeah I just put this outfit
together oh and your skins mustard I
said it
Alba said all that's racist no your skin
your luster do you have John oh you
don't know for certain I live now cuz
that's racist you said I have yellow
skin no that's not what I said
oh um I have a dash a dash of Asian
we're already in trouble you're in
trouble you're in trouble
I like how I did get a lot of a race I
got a lot of Asian American people that
hit me up and they were pissed not only
were they pissed they were like I'm not
listening to the show anymore God but
but I understand because I think it's a
no hold on don't say this no please
Lauren Steve I said this before I've
said that people always forget cuz
because Chinese Americans Chinese expat
Chinese all over the world have done
incredibly well in every in every
culture Koreans have done incredibly
well Vietnamese done incredibly well in
every culture they've embedded
themselves in ok and I've always said
that they we don't talk enough about how
much they've been discriminated ok but
their culture seems to be the kind of
culture that gets them to excel the boys
were Harvard is see they're suing
Harvard on a class-action suit because
apparently Harvard things are too many
quote unquote Asians I understand I
understand I've said that before having
said that let's go back to whether or
not somebody should lose their job
because they made a comment from what I
heard I'm doubling down from what I
heard it's not like he said this is what
other people say about that particular
house yeah he kind of doubled down if
anything he and I've said this from the
jump he should've been fired for having
a bad podcast the problem is it was it
funny and it was like reckless and I get
they just wasn't funny but I did have
some asian-americans I think they're
Asian Americans could just be agents DME
and go Brennan get your opinion all good
how would you feel if you use the n-word
replace what he said the [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I like saying it but replace [ __ ] Reese
and word would you still defend them
what oh I wouldn't
they went in that way like I literally
had this dialogue with sky goes in that
weird intelligent it's all good because
they [ __ ] cuz you don't think that says
why do you think it was good I don't use
I don't know I don't say it's good but I
didn't think you but they go even if he
was saying out of context the n-word
would you still defend my oh I wouldn't
well I went oh I get it
well I get I think I kind of get I think
you can say any word depending on
context well I don't think and use the
n-word well I I think you can use the
n-word if you use it in context right
also I see I don't think you can't
that's fine
but but I I would but see I don't think
you can but I also think it up because
it's a product of the environment I grew
up in yeah and I was young gotcha where
is mainly african-american so like that
word carried so much way yeah you gotta
be carefully all watch your P's and Q's
yes so to me I'm like I went never the
reason I wouldn't use that word that
I've never used that word
okay [ __ ] or whatever among the f-word
of him whatever it is I don't want to
make people feel bad and I'm very aware
it's derogatory I'm very aware it was
used in a very derogatory so guess what
but now I don't do that because I don't
I don't do it because I'm gonna get in
trouble I don't do it because I am aware
that it hurts people's feelings that is
shitty and I don't want to be that guy
how is it possible that this guy is not
racist
what's said was saying he was using it
in how people say that particular house
is now a little Brody did tell me if you
keep going back there's worse stuff than
this so like if it wasn't this it
would've been something so he's
insensitive but not race he's also
really good comic you know but that was
the problem with that where you don't
see like very many good community
offending him because they thought
[ __ ] yeah well what I would say is
this he's insensitive
scold him and get him get him to see
like educate the dude get to get him to
see hey hey dude hey hey this this sucks
this sucks for the history here's the
history behind this word this is what it
was like to be chinese-american it's
what it was like to be Korean memory
this is what the [ __ ] in the history of
this country where it sucked
where you were a third class citizen in
a second okay but but when you fire
somebody when you say you're out to me
that's canceled culture and to me you're
not making the world a better if it
makes it worse right but also
is how about this so we're in the
parking lot of the economy store last
night all the comics while we're all
talking and we're talking about this
situation we were Tim Dylan who is a gay
man right yeah and that's I'm not outing
that it's well documented so we're all
talking in a group Santino Tim some
other guys
daliyah's there Brian Brian comes up in
his Tesla
I always make fun of Brian instead I
know if you even noticed this Brian come
is Tesla I make a remark about how Gaede
is driving the Tesla front of Tim
Hammett and the other guy I think is
this boyfriend
I don't know how might be his boyfriend
I didn't I yell out a derogatory term of
driving a Tesla now it's a baby wasn't
Roger I said gay I said yeah but you in
a dirt but in a way that was way harder
on me yeah yeah making fun of you but
because of Brian but I don't have a I
don't have listen I think Tess is great
I think the technology behind its fame
you're very silly that's the future
playing we always we always joke route
in my Aston Martin was there and park in
front of it so it's a bit we always do
and daliyah's in on it yeah but Tim's
there who's a gay man I said it and as
it's come now it you [ __ ] yeah whatever
everyone laughed him laughter when
laughed but all I could think about the
whole night the whole night I get home
right around midnight or whatever I text
him I go dude I know we're comics I
don't say a lot of [ __ ] I probably need
to tell you this but just to make me
feel better
because I'm a narcissist just make me
feel better when Brian pull up in this
Tesla I called it gay I feel terrible
about it and I wait wait wait then I get
back reven listen you definitely don't
need apologize for that I get rid of
coming from you're not a home look like
you know he's cool about it he's also
he's such a dude and he hangs Howard
nothing but straight I loved him like
yeah unless he told you you would never
be like no Ismail Issac fo but there was
I do what I get you want to keep them
included you don't wanna hurt no he's
our friend
yeah you don't wanna [ __ ] no no it
always comes down to me it always comes
out of not hurt anybody's feelings
yeah I was like I just don't want I know
like Ross so he's not gonna acknowledge
it there that hurt his feelings but what
if it did and then he's new you know
he's kind of newer do the thing he's
around so I don't want to be like got
[ __ ] you know look here's the bottom
line I think you should always be able
to apologize it so at the times I've
heard people's feelings whether the men
are women
whether that I misread something and and
I know I got a call from somebody said
you know you treated me this way and I
think it was a shitty way I called them
so quickly because I decided it wasn't
about getting in trouble I just didn't
want I don't want bad energy I didn't
want them to feel bad man I don't I want
to be like I'm sorry there's nothing
what I was saying I'm sorry there's
nothing wrong with being like I didn't
[ __ ] know I did I [ __ ] up they said
by the way we're allowed to go I [ __ ]
up I'm sorry I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
yeah but I yet I care what my friends
think yeah and that's it you can't you
can't satellite to your PB you also
don't want to lend yourself to the
chorus of pile on you want to be piling
on somebody has already been made fun of
historically you know so in r08 I grew
up around my cousin was murdered for
being gay like him very sensitive yeah
they had that they had nothing to do
with that fact and here's the thing Tim
with a quiet night what the [ __ ]
you might be gay you know what I mean
what do you I'm saying what the promise
he went well the problem is it's Brian's
a very gay 51 year old man no no 15 you
throw that so Adam you know I did no no
because you live in this truth now no no
but you might know and I and really when
you're drunk you're drunk maybe you do
stuff you know what I mean maybe you do
stuff who knows you've made a pass at me
that's the how dare you we were drunk
and I and you went you you're good or
something like that now right and you
were towering right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]